you use quantum physics every single day
as you go about your life something you
probably don't realize because when
people talk about quantum physics
including me we tend to emphasize more
crazy aspects of it like particles that
can be separated by the size of the
universe and still communicate with each
other instantaneously or when particles
could be in multiple places at once or
multiple positions and this tends to
make quantum physics seem like this
really strange abstract crazy
kind of physics that doesn't have much
to do with our everyday lives but this
couldn't be further from the truth so
this is a list of five ways we use
quantum physics every single day number
one on the list is the entire basis of
the modern world it's computers and
computers wouldn't exist if it wasn't
for our understanding of quantum physics
the basic element of computer is the
transistor which is a tiny little switch
it's very useful because it doesn't have
any moving parts in it which is allowed
us to miniaturize it and have billions
of them on a single chip all switching a
billion times per second
transistors use the special electronic
properties of silicon which is a
semiconductor and the rules of
semiconductors are dictated by quantum
physics
now electrons in a semiconductor can
only be in certain energy states and you
can use these energy states to create on
on-off switches now you can't do a whole
lot with just pure silicon you need to
engineer these materials by adding in
extra elements like phosphorous or boron
to make materials with different energy
levels and by combining those materials
you can make a junction where normally
electrons don't flow until you apply a
voltage and then electrons can flow and
that's how you make an on and off switch
in how are the energy levels behave in
these different materials that's
dictated by the laws of quantum physics
and we wouldn't have been able to invent
the transistor without this
understanding now my technology 2 and 3
the screen that you're watching this on
and also the camera that I recorded this
on which both also rely on the quantum
physics of semiconductors most screens
today a backlit by LEDs light emitting
diodes and these are semiconductor
devices that when you apply a voltage an
electron goes from one semiconductor to
another it loses energy and then
some light so LEDs have been gradually
getting better over time and a lot of
engineering effort has gone into making
LEDs that are very bright and also white
in color now kind of the opposite of an
LED is number three which is the sensor
in my digital camera that sensor is made
up of loads of tiny little pixels called
photo detectors or photo diodes and
these when they receive light they
create a current of electrons again
through our manipulation of the energy
levels in semiconductors part of the
reason why these cameras have kept
getting better with more megapixels and
higher sensitivities is our increasing
ability to engineer the quantum physics
of these semiconductors now technology
number four is the laser in a laser you
apply voltage to specific mixtures of
elements and excite the electrons and
then they give off light this is
amplified with mirrors and finally gives
off very strong focused monochromatic
light the process that lasers use is
called stimulated emission where you
promote an electron to a higher energy
state in one atom transfer it to another
atom and then those electrons get
knocked down with a correctly tuned
theme of light which releases more light
which is all in phase and to make a
laser beam work you need to find these
elements that have very similar energy
levels again which requires our
understanding of quantum physics now you
might be wondering how you use laser
beams every day well this video probably
got to you through a fiber optic cable
as a laser beam as does a huge amount of
web traffic these days now the last
technology on my list number 5 is GPS
technology GPS relies on incredibly
accurate clocks on GPS satellites the
satellites continuously broadcast their
time and your phone takes these signals
and can work out where it is on earth
depending on how long the signals took
to get to it the ticking of these atomic
clocks depends on the frequency of a
transition between two particular energy
states in a cesium atom because the
frequency of these clocks depends on the
laws of nature all of the clocks are
exactly in time and are accurate to one
second in 1.4 million years
so those are my five main technologies
that perhaps you didn't know based on
the laws of quantum physics but there's
loads of other ones that we use in the
world today and because these days we do
pretty much everything on computers you
could argue that the entire modern world
exists because of our understanding of
quantum physics which is something I
don't think many people appreciate but I
think is super cool and in the future
there's more quantum technologies coming
on like quantum information quantum
computing quantum metrology and quantum
simulation and seeing how all of these
develop is going to be it's going to be
very fascinating clearly I'm a massive
fan of quantum physics but I think I'll
give it a rest there thanks so much for
watching
and if you'd like to support me there's
many different ways you can buy a poster
or a book we've just released the new
professor a stroke a tap a link to all
of that in the description below and any
support on patreon is gratefully
received thanks for watching and I'll
see you on the next video